we have four players left in this
tournament from four different countries
that's great hmm you don't get that kind
of diversity everywhere and I'm doing
you know really don't but we did talk
about this matchup earlier right I'm
musician for some ek we did see this
matchup happen kind of recently that red
bag dude yeah oh yeah I keep forgetting
that what happened it did not go well
for a night yeah that's why it was he
did not have and I feel like this is
even better for him I feel like a coma
fits his playstyle so well like I didn't
think about it until I saw him do it on
my toe so also a K is not affected by
the if it's your first time playing your
role right yes two sets with it yeah
okay well there we go
fine I remember this is loser semis not
losers finals yet so this only be at
first two - yeah this winner of this
match whatever this bet is gonna be
facing off against book from Thailand
yeah somebody's going home
look at baby spectator mode that was
sick I never thought I would see that he
just reflected the fireball Wow was his
umbrella Twitter Clips right dancing a
little bit down for I think I think this
is a do you think that this cool think
is the right pick for a K in this
mansion right especially to go so well
friend yeah sure he did it just in time
look at the distance all right you've
got the combos talent yeah you see him
throwing up fireballs because you too
chunky like to take a fireball to your
back yeah yeah like there's times away
see what you gonna do he's gonna busy
the staff oh my gosh you went first and
it worked
that was sick and yet you armored
through that fireball - yeah took a
little bit of damage oh there's a lot of
life ahead by the range awesome
it's crazy oh my god
but you're right what's the man that he
likes to like I stay at mid-range I just
go back to him to heal
can't do that became five we'll check
that yard yeah I remember that was the
issue with a came in the first set when
he played a musician because when you
place your heat you know you like to do
the slide mix up in the middle value but
you can't do that it gets you shouldn't
refused to keep getting fighting like
that upstairs the flash punish a man a
hurricane kick in the wall - this is
gonna be big what's the mix-up it wasn't
ready he knows now that one sent me to
you soccer they work in that situation
probably we go for the town for
afterwards well as soon as he find
himself into that range you know he
managed to get the round still don't
keep my braids dangerous especially with
me to which he does have oh my gosh you
would three the triple double boy that's
slide yeah I love the way uses downpour
to those fireballs you got to be careful
though this is good for make a you're
staying that made strain just to you
know threatened musician this is optimal
right now I mean meter where you have
down more I agree she looks like in
playing a cure for the first time like
this is like pre-release this is the
taste of his own medicine what a healthy
yeah what do I do
I bet you he didn't forget about their
Rev major man oh
boo-ki me the follow up here he's gonna
get to the wall
very good dangers not the hope of them
you had will be good yeah be careful do
that but it was nice oh we're gonna put
them in the rage yep four four two one
no lows for hurricane kick the wall was
right there wow this jumps back nice
block
he got greedy I think it was crazy that
he was so prepared for that option right
away he ended every round first time on
the tour you want everyone with a
diamond must have hit like every you
guys are practicing stats back at home
that's the perfect match demon rate
alright okay this is this is a musician
this is the this is where his beat drops
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
nice start more for four fours now cuz
those downpours are gonna get a blocky
and on top of these tries to spin up
closer he has a better chance catcher he
just won't let it do the healing but if
you keep on trying on those 500 you
hesitated hi musician okay the stage big
deputy working off premiere two rounds
up in the second game I think he loves
the stage for the beat
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
condom what will hey whatever hello he
had done Danny today probably could I
felt and I thought felt like it would
have worked three around straight there
we're gonna be great to a final match to
see who's gonna get into top three to
fight against book in the losers finals
yeah he's gonna he's definitely gonna
pick some walls there's gonna be walls
here yeah we'll be home you didn't think
about switching characters this time no
especially home from what you mention
man if you lost that badly wish you he
knew you're gonna do that Howard is take
mr. Howard we said there will be walls
there's more whatever you got man
whatever you got I got a match to finish
it
why are those walls even there there's
no doors let the intro rock I got into
the slide doors you got to show all the
camera is just coming in through all the
tool comes out to this will it be the
Philippines or Korea moving on here it's
gonna be a double ko to play another one
yeah stop imagine my head would explode
it's happened today
the he's using those downforce you can
feel it all back there coming out so do
you need my fourth board for town yeah
he hasn't really been all warlord water
oh my gosh light above light him up
easy ok would they advantage it close to
one meter here this is where it's gonna
count cause you know the pacing of the
matchup the amount of meter he's able to
build it's already been proven that 18
does not need to use the meter to deal
damage oh my god wall break oh he's he's
doing sup stop them right now I'm using
close your eyes oh my god I just like
that okay is on sad point yeah they live
in a Korea from the toilet
yep I'm are you good maybe you got the
wall here what's gonna do wake up flash
no lost tons to do that's the thing he
got two huge big level to focus on to
stay alive in this bracket but guys
please do me a favor make some noise for
rocks dragons I musician he has been
phenomenal all year and I'm telling you
right now
we had a Yoshi this close this close man
definitely looking forward to seeing him
more in the future as well I'm musician
man yeah what it was really cool thing
that um the fact that first off bronze
dragons has him on the team and he's put
on each showed out so far I mean what a
great shine with Yoshimitsu nonetheless
he knows I'm a little y'all know he
understood me but I definitely told I
grow up I'll faint